stelle war ja gestern direkt vom
ortsschild bubenheim dass es eine kleine
gemeinde mit 800 einwohnern in
rheinhessen und ziemlich kleine
landstraße wie man sieht also man hat
kaum da ist auch ein mittelstreifen zu
sehen nichts rechts und links gibt es
keine ausweichmöglichkeiten für die
radfahrer oder 14 laufen also ziemlich
enge straße die kleine ortschaft führt
weiß man bereits etwas zu den beiden
opfern oder zu dem unglücksfahrer ja das
hat sich natürlich herumgesprochen laufe
der unglücksfahrer der 66 jährige helmut
r
estland wird hier in bubenheim er war
auch über 40 jahre bei der freiwilligen
feuerwehr engagiert war oft selbst bei
rettungseinsätzen also hier kann es kaum
gehabt hat und deshalb die kontrolle
über sein fahrzeug verloren hat